herzlich kommen zu einer neuen folge ich
fahre leute heute in diesem video fahren
wir ein absolutes eisenstein und eins
meiner absoluten lieblingsautos leute
wir sehen uns hier drüben audi s
[Musik]
bausch
juni
das ist der wagen von jenen zeit christi
brüder als fullservice jammern let's go
okay also ich habe schon gesagt audi s8
finde ich turbo turbo geil weil ich bin
mit audio aufgewachsen habe ich schon
ein paar videos gesagt mein papa mal
audi gefahren mein onkel war audi
gefahren und ich fand bei audi immer
schon geil dass die so absurde
dieselmotoren hat also klar ist ja die
mlb plattform also der touareg hat ja
auch den gleichen motor hier drin den v8
biturbo diesel aber das ist einfach
anders leute kommt warum hier auf die
felgen schaut euch diese felgen war an
das sind 22 zoll und co was hier noch
anregungen dran ist der könnte
wahrscheinlich jetzt kannst du auch mein
geld eben schon 23 zoll ist gar kein
problem und das soll auf jeden fall ja
theoretisch also war es auch noch glück
gummi für 24 wahrscheinlich ist dann
halt immer eine frage von fahrkomfort ja
also wir müssen aber sexy alter war geil
geil geil kommen wir diese linie hier
und ich saß gerade eben schon als wir
her gefahren sind hinten drin und vor
mir saß ich bin 191 groß und diese
dachten die geht also runter man denkt
sich so allerdings kein platz vier drin
überhaupt kein problem erst mal hatte
ich nach vorn gefühlten meter hat sich
angefühlt als welchem a8 und oben war
auch echt echt locker dass man von unten
anschauen übrigens ihr haben wir auch
mal sehen was hier vorne und hinten 285
er breite drauf und das ist sexy auf
jeden fall das schwarze logo hinten kann
man das kann bei audi so bestellen ja
ich hab dann aber nachträglich noch
gemacht er hatte ursprünglich hatte die
alles in silber abgesetzt und hinten ja
und bin aber bisher ist noch dazu
gekommen ich hab das auto erst zwei
wochen ja die nachträglich die ringe in
schwarz zu machen ist geil ja sieht auf
jeden fall schon finde ich finde ich
richtig geil so aus ich muss aber auch
sagen mit einer der wahrscheinlich auch
eine der einzige sache die ich an diesem
auto stören du kennst du ja auch keiner
wirklich weiß was ist das denn hier mal
da okay haben wir erstmal eine blende
drüber immerhin ist auch ein auspuffrohr
da hinten und hier ist einfach das ist
einfach nur schauen muss ich sagen
wirklich eine sache mit der xtra gehabt
bei audi hier drüben ist es noch mal das
gleiche spiel eine eine blende hat
natürlich auch eine rolle dahinter und
das andere ist einfach nur für den spaß
aber besser noch als glaube ich glaube
der s6 hat nur noch fade blenden ja ja
der neue das ja richtig geil alltag
richtig geil leute v8 biturbo diesel mit
noch mehr elektrischen verdichter 435 ps
900 newtonmeter die neun meter liegen ab
1052 und regen schon an wegen dem
elektrischen verluste
ihr wisst was ich meine und
48 sekunden 0 auf 100 und ja einfach ich
habe am anfang eisenstein gesagt weiss 1
3440 kilo komplett banane dkv 8 ist aber
dass lieblichkeit was ist denn v8-diesel
biturbo für ein gestörter motor ist
einfach da und dann können wir sie mal
anschauen
bruder er ist richtig geil leute
rahmenlosen scheiben sexy vorne und
hinten
let's go und ganz wichtig die müller
die leute immer fürs training mal rein
ja das sieht auch schon richtig geil aus
diese sitze oder
extrem nochmal am montag fort egal ob
das ist so ein auto ich das ist für mich
eigentlich der perfekte daily driver
kann man kann sagen ja ist unpraktisch
weil warum so ein schweres auto
aber guckt einfach hier
muss man noch mehr sagen
gut da abdeckung darüber aber man sieht
auf jeden fall schon da ist schon ein
ordentlicher klotz drin v8 das finde ich
echt geil aber auch der q7 früher im v12
diese das ist einfach das einfach der
wahnsinn wir wollen kann man nicht
anders sagen
ich gebe ich gebe auch die noch so zwei
jahren hast du dann irgendwie vorne auch
so ein knopf für die motorhaube ja ok
darüber müssen vielleicht auch noch mal
reden schaut nochmal rein erst mal geil
hier schöne cantare erreichen dass ich
bin einfach auch die geschädigte ich
weiß ihr seid auch bmw jungs da draußen
mit cds draußen für mich ist es einfach
audi immer weil halt meine fans und guck
mal hier das ist aber eine sache sagen
deine meinung dazu jetzt dass du jetzt
hier noch über einen bildschirm hast ja
sogar klima ist ja auf diesem bildschirm
drauf also ich muss sagen ich habe jetzt
vorher in 62 coupé gefahren daher war
halt noch viel mit knöpfen schaltern und
ich warne ist gewöhnungssache ja wenn
ich ganz ehrlich aber wenn man am ende
dann einfach nur sieben hat nur noch
einen drehregler für lauter und leiser
zu machen und die startknopf ist halt
schon schön ist auch klar ist aber es
fragt sich jetzt nicht ab dass wir da
immer drauf hast oder irgendwie so man
muss halt ein bisschen pflegen ja man
muss ein bisschen fliegen aber geht klar
meinte ja es ist auf jeden fall schon
schick ganz wichtig auch der soundcheck
jens zum auto gerettet wird jetzt einmal
für uns auf die hupe dreht
den richtigen motor arbeiten tatsächlich
einen sound
[Applaus]
die so schnell aufgeben
hier suchen wir für euch sollte der
innenraum
wo sieht das ganze aus sehr schönes
digitales cockpit das file server vielen
herstellern wird manchmal auch und hier
haben wir einmal diese beiden großen
touchscreen sobald alles bedienen kann
hier radio medien musikern hier unten
die die auto elemente sage ich jetzt mal
hier die die sitzheizung und so weiter
und so fort ist schon frech wirklich
jedes mal wenn ich in so einem high
class audi sitze denke ich mir ich fahre
zwar noch ein test und zwar einmal noch
mal eine richtig lange latte hier nehmen
dass marx kumpel von mir du bist 1 93
so ok dann setzen wir einmal 198 typen
vornherein in den es kracht so kommen
warum max stellt jetzt mal den sitz so
ein dass er für die bequeme ist locker
isin das komplett entspannt okay so dass
jetzt stellt sich einmal dahinter zwar
zwei meter mann vor mir ich 191 habe
oben gar keine probleme weil hier das
ist locker also es ist nicht gleich viel
luft aber ich habe gar keinen stress
damit einfach geil wenn einer von euch
noch 1,8 übrig hat meldet euch mir jetzt
fahren wir und damit setzen wir endlich
leute im sq 8
guck mal hier mal da es ist einfach da
ich finde es einfach anders geil leute
bin einfach ich bin auch eine frau die
kennt muss ich auch sagen es ist einfach
boston alles geil aus jetzt am steuer
vor gern los jens wenn du nicht
wohlfühlt wir haben heute einen voll
besetzten wagen ja zu den 2,4 tonnen
kommen noch viele passagiere dazu und
natürlich hier zunächst kommen wir uns
beiden ist auch da und deren bruder ben
ist auch hinten rechts mit der kamera
denn ben wird uns bei diesem wird mich
bei diesem video und bei vielen in der
zukunft unterstützen leute ihr habt mir
sicher auch schon gesehen dass die
produktionsqualität jetzt ganz andere
ist jetzt kommen
diese sätze waren er ist so die serien
sind also die serien sind die sind
normalerweise mit nach hause bangkok
kopfstütze hat ja nur und da fand ich
jetzt hat die s line sitzt also die es
sitze da schon auch deutlich besser als
auch erika ich dieses auto sogar schönen
sitz geben doch rein machen was uns
sitzt klima kfd egal das ist nämlich
auch mal sagen leute der wagen ist volle
hütte
150000 höchster hast du gesagt 150.000
150000 decker andere leute wohnen in
sachen 450.000 aber es ist auch einfach
geil muss man sagen aber sag mal erste
frage immer was bedeuten autos finde ich
ja das ist eine gute frage ich meine
klar man hat immer so ein bisschen
diesem bezug zur autos gehabt jeder von
uns hat glaube ich fast furious gesehen
jeder vom land selber mal den traum
gehabt mal schöne autos zu fahren
herrmann ich bei mir ist das damals so
gewesen ich bin mein erstes auto war
damals ein opel corsa sondern standard
ja dann habe ich ein bisschen geld
gespart habe direktmarketing golf er
gekauft da war ich 19 krass und wenn du
immer so ein sportliches auto gefahren
bist dann bleibst du im prinzip immer so
ein bisschen dabei danach kam 10 45 dann
habe ich den rs3 gefahren dann erst war
dann zuletzt der c63 da war so mein
traumwagen immer den habe ich mir dann
vor zwei jahren gekauft und
irgendwann kam aber dann so der punkt wo
ich gesagt hab irgendwie diese extreme
sportlichkeit ist auf dauer anstrengend
und ja dann kam die überlegung nationen
als cd zu kaufen der gefühle ich
komplett ich hatte auch den c 63 mal als
daily driver und das ist auch für mich
zu viel größer große ab den wir so einen
will ich nicht daily fahren kein bock
dass hier das kann halt alles
individuelle dafür liebig hat audi das
diese verrückte dieselmotoren bauen
v8 biturbo diesel 435 serie wie gesagt
und du kannst da mit einer
leistungssteigerung ganz einfach
stiftung kommst du dann ruckzuck auf 520
ps er hat die 1000 1000 meter im prinzip
schon erste chiptuning erste schnee hat
man ja auf jeden fall locker 1000 das
ist einfach länger das ist einfach geil
muss man einfach sein drücken jetzt
einfach mal machen das hat man zu gucken
wir kommen
eltern boa hat er hat den pantschen 900
newtonmeter sind kein pappenstiel weil
leute wie gesagt er hat einen
elektrischen verdichter also über das 48
volt bordnetz einen verdichter der quasi
in dem bereich schon verdichtet und die
arbeit macht ihr eigentlich turbolader
machen auch in dem bereich wo das
abkommen noch nicht groß genug ist um
dem turbolader anzutreiben dadurch hat
er halt bei 1250 umdrehungen was halt
gar nix ist das ist knapp über
leerlaufdrehzahl
acht sekunden 0 auf 100 er habe und wo
du hast natürlich auch die sound
aktuator noch im innenraum aber ist
schon geil wenn ich hier bin das ist
sogar leute ich hab mich rechts raus
top-note racks wir dürfen da nicht rein
wir sind wir zu schwer war geil der
partner ich liebe dieses auto wirklich
hammer also man kann auch wirklich wenn
man den jetzt einfach mal fährt jetzt
eine ganze zeit und dann sandte okay im
dynamic modus muss ich sagen für ein suv
merkt war schon die unebenheiten in der
straße ganz gut ja dann stellen wir
jetzt einfach mal wir stellen ist
einfach mal eine komfort modus dann
fährt der automat stadt luftfahrwerk
schon hoch da zeigen hier an
den wagen jetzt an und dann fährst du
über eine straße drüber und du merkst
die eingeschränkt ist einfach dann
fahrkomfort der kammer 8 98 900 tausend
kilometer am stück bestimmt waren ohne
probleme
masala wie geil alter
ist dass
mich das ganz vergessen ist ein
luftfahrwerk an noch drin
hanna ist auf jeden fall jetzt jetzt ein
bisschen klassischen musik
wir können euch doch mal wechseln wenn
du magst ja ja ich mache jetzt einfach
mal hier ja noch ne sache leute sehr
interessant wäre es auch gerne auf
können beim einsteigen wie hast du es
genannt diese all diesen raum gesucht
aromatisierung einfach aromatisierung
und so wie wir es jetzt verstanden haben
ist die im motorraum mode unter dem
motorrad versteckt genau man kommt gar
nicht als fahrer dran man kann ich
selbst finde man muss zu audi für den
service scheinbar so dass jetzt unser
stand geil digger kamerad begrüßung
sound naja
das ist ein echt und head-up-display und
alles ist da ja leck mich doch einmal
fett leute das dass das für mich echt
krass weil bevor ich dieses auto video
dieses auto vom hat angefangen habe
hatte mein onkel auch tatsächlich in
asco acht mein onkel ist ein absoluter
auto mensch und ich habe immer mit dem
asco 8 gesehen und ich dachte mir immer
die gabor ist das ein geiles auto aber
wirst du ihn gefahren weil michael es
nicht waren der ist sogar das auto für
die die last der ist niemand und jetzt
sollte das immer auf der autobahn hinter
uns ein hyundai was das e20 oder so der
auf jeden fall der es eilig hat er uns
dampf macht natürlich wollen wir uns
davon nicht bedrängen lassen und
entfernen uns mal von diesem rüpel
in windeseile
der punch der schiebt der schienen
schieben
der schiebt ok 114 115 vermerk japan
entspannen davon schwer
170-180
schon bisher immer noch da wo ist das
ruhig
jetzt wo es gebe dazu ist 200 hallo
hallo
es ist ja so ruhig alter what the [ __ ]
von merck geschwindigkeit und sich
überhaupt nicht
überhaupt nicht nur wenn das jetzt
zügige autobahn kurven hast dann da
merkst du auch wenn ich so ein bisschen
das was da sind bei kiel auf der werft
da ist sie mit dem auto aber
der ist ja so unfassbar gut isoliert
genau das ist quasi der der hässliche
bruder von sma
marek
geile kombination der motor in dem autos
dann richtig geile kombination ja
verrückt crazy schweineteuer und drüber
aber geil sollte freie autobahn wir
lassen jetzt es ist das erste mal
anschluss noch nie gelernt vielen vielen
dank für diese ehre das tier erst mal
ein schock wir sind beide bisschen
eventuell ein bisschen logik unserer
ansicht ist einfach bremse und rheingas
bisschen drei pumpen und dann ja ja ja
ja und 3 21 jahren
850 pence bergab da rennt die kuh junge
let's go go lasst sogar mein handy aus
der tasche gefallen naja kraft
geiles auto aber leute schreibt mir mal
in die kommentare was ihr machen würde
sagen wir mal ihr habt 150000 euro
budget und hat ein auto ein daily driver
welches auto überholen könnte man die
kommentare schreiben diskutiert gerne
mal jetzt kommen auch die nachtsicht
assistenten zum beispiel sind 88 auch ja
wenn man werde jetzt weiter schaltest
auf den hier der feier rechts genau
weiter weiter so jetzt
da ist jetzt einfach eine
wärmebildkamera moral und sie erkennt
zum beispiel fußgänger und war dann
zum beispiel witziges zog ich bin
letztes nachts einfach bei mir durch die
stadt gefahren und die bei uns in der
gegend ist das so die blenden einfach
abends die platzherren aus ja ok und
dann ist ein fußgänger der hergelaufen
und dann hat er denn angeleuchtet damit
und denn sie ist das auto ja ja das auto
leuchtet den fußgänger automatisch damit
du denn nicht überfährt er denn so
dreimal an geblitzt
so zu drei fotos untereinander
das ist doch einfach krank das ist doch
einfach krank ernsthaft hammer was alles
geht also wirklich langsam damit bekommt
langsam angst dass die autos und fünf
jahren ersetzen 15 54 produzieren die
autos menschen also ihr habt mir zuerst
gehörte und damit muss ich sagen go pro
daher würde ich sagen jens vielen vielen
dank dass ich fahren durfte gerne ab in
die bewertung heute die bewertung fängt
man mit dem aussehen an der asco 8 ist
auf jeden fall ein sehr schönes auto
schwarz meiner meinung nach genau die
richtige farbe die 22 zöller sie ein
richtig geiles die schwarzen audi logos
das macht schon einiges her aber muss
bei aller liebe auf höherer weil sie
sagen das sind 54 oder ein turbo s
einfach noch eine ecke schöner ist acht
von zehn die beschleunigung fühlt sich
brutal an dadurch das ganz frühe
anliegen drehmoment von 90 meter schon
bei 1250 umdrehungen ist aber auf dem
papier bei 4,8 sekunden von null auf
hundert schnell aber nicht super schnell
sieben von zehn cool ist das auto aber
auch auf jeden fall ich finde es richtig
richtig fresh ist sieht einfach geil aus
diese coupéform klar man kann sagen
coupé suv ist wer braucht das mal gar
keinen sinn aber ich finde ich finde es
eine coole kiste acht von zehn damit
kommen der spaß wertung auf 23 von 30
punkten und platz acht die
praktikabilität ist haben wir du hast
richtig viel platz du kannst 22 meter
männer hintereinander reinsetzen du hast
ordentlich laderaum wenn man will kann
man den wagen mit acht litern bewegen
man hat eine anhängelast von bis zu
dreieinhalb tonnen wenn man eine
anhängerkupplung hat dass es richtig
klingt vielleicht komisch aber neun von
zehn preis leistung natürlich wieder die
leute liste kostet der wagen 150000 euro
jens hat den modell 2020 mit 16.000
kilometer ich sehe aber aufgrund der
wertstabilität dadurch dass der wagen
seit 20 20h produziert wird und der neue
benziner ist ein v8 diesel einfach geil
ist trotzdem eine ganz gute prognose 7
von 10 zuletzt der komfort ist einfach
ein absoluter traum luftfahrwerk auf
komfort und du schwebst über die straße
das einzige was noch komfortabler es ist
vielleicht ein rolls royce oder eine
krasse s-klasse oder maybach richtig
richtig strong neun von zehn alltags
wert und damit 25 von 30 und ein
geteilter erster platz mit dem golf plus
von meiner mama mal richtig spannend
wird es aber bei der gesamtbewertung da
holt der asco achten nämlich 48 von 60
punkten er ist eine eierlegende
wollmilchsau muss man wirklich sagen
geteilter erster platz mit den
bisherigen spitzenreiter betis amg 63
esco 8 für mich ein absolutes traumauto
wenn 120 rex rumliegen hat meldet euch
bei mir ich könnte gebrochen bis
nächsten sonntag